si vous avez suivi l'actualité google
est revenu sur le devant de la scène
avec un nouveau smartphone on attendait
depuis quelques temps c'est le pixel 4
parce que l'année dernière ils sont
arrivés avec le pixel 3 et pixel 3xl
puis ensuite le pixel 3 au fc3a ils
s'aiment mais surtout de pixels 3 parce
que le 3 à ses modèles moyen de gamme
avec le pixel 3 on était dans le haut de
gamme et surtout dans un smartphone qui
a vraiment marqué au niveau de la
photographie en proposant un truc qui
est officier en termes de photos avec un
seul capteur est derrière beaucoup de
puissance made in google pour les
calculs bad 5 ça ça marchait
parfaitement niaréla ils sont revenus et
je vous en ai parlé à quelques jours
vous emmener avec moi à new york pour
aller voir la présentation toussa toussa
toussa toussa avec le pixel 4 alors ce
pixel 4 il fait vraiment de très belles
promesses déjà en termes de photos on va
plus loin on a un double capteur photo à
l'arrière on a pas mal de nouveautés au
point de vue matériel au point de vue
logiciel
il ya des avancées il ya de très jolies
promesses au niveau la photographie on
va donc se poser la question aujourd'hui
à savoir si google a tenu ses promesses
avec son pixels 4
ou alors pas du tout
[Musique]
non
on va y aller franco avec ce smartphone
ya des choses qui vont parfaitement bien
qu'ils sont vraiment aux boks qui est
maîtrisé et extrêmement bien maîtrisée
par contre ce qui va pas mais bon ça n'a
vraiment pas comment son temps
commencement le design on un seul modèle
qui en france je sais que tout le monde
n'est pas en france mais pour ceux qui
sont en france on a un seul modèle c'est
le modèle noir
il n'y a pas de gros il n'ya pas
d'orange dont le modèle noir fonctionne
500 est bien à minima d'avoir le modèle
blanc sans lui permettre un petit peu de
d'augmenter le choix fois de s'arrêter
cool à côté se retrouve avec ici un
double module photo qui je trouve
beaucoup et pas trop mal intégrés noir
sûrement comme ça ça fonctionne tout le
tour je voulais déjà fait le jo donc
jours passent très très très très
rapidement là dessus l'autre point
essentiel c'est le design au niveau de
la face avant
google s'est pas énormément renouveler
là dessus quelque chose de très
classique on trouve un smartphone avec
une grande bordure en eau qui vous
permet de loger une caméra normale et
puis deux caméras infrarouges et votre
haut parleurs et puis une bordure sur le
banc déborde sur les côtés qui sont pas
les plus petits du monde mais qui
fonctionne sur un smartphone comme ça
c'est vrai qu'il n'ya pas de prise de
risque on n'en trouve pas sur un
smartphone bord à bord c'est déjà le cas
l'année dernière avec le pixel 3 c'est
toujours le cas cette année avec le
pixel 4
à côté de ça c'est un truc qui marche
plutôt pas mal les angles de vision sont
pas mal le smartphone se tient est assez
joli donc ça me convient effectivement
cette grande bande you lie pas génial
mais je la préfère quand même à une
encoche qui vient vous mangez une partie
du contenu on a un écran oled de 5,7
pouces que je trouve plutôt pas mal et
surtout le point qui très très fort là
dessus c'est que ça à l'écran 90 à 180
dire que ça va vous apporter quoi ça
vous apporte de la fluidité lorsque vous
allez venir scrollé lorsque vous allez
venir jouer à des jeux 5 7 pouces fhd
plus ce ratio 19/9 ça marche l'écran 90
on l'avait déjà dans le one + 7 t au et
de +7 et pro c'est bien ça porte de la
fluidité sans marge d'un expérience est
vraiment cool là dessus en plus de ça il
ya une gestion qui est intelligente qui
fait par google
vous avez dans affichage fluide pouvait
venir l'actif d'ailleurs jouent leurs
commandes augmentent automatiquement la
fréquence d'actualisation de 60 à 80 des
aides pour certains contenus à croix
l'utilisation de la batterie pour qu'en
fonction des applications que vous allez
utiliser vous allez soutien en 89 et
sinon pour vous avez pas besoin vous
restez en 60 hertz
parce que forcément vous en douterez le
90 et son avenir pomper peu plus du côté
de la batterie puisse couler dans les
paramètres d'affichage à notre truc qui
est bien c'est ça la ambiante et ku qui
est juste dynamiquement l'écran en
fonction des niveaux de luminosité
environnement bon jeu voulu tout
simplement ce qui est écrit mais croyez
moi c'est pas mal
effectivement aussi une fête plus
devenir adapté complètement votre
smartphone
un autre point qui est pas mal c'est la
concentration sur l'écran ce qui fait
que lorsque vous allez lire votre
smartphone donc vous êtes de sutton vous
allez regarder du contenu est bien votre
écran ne s'éteindra pas la caméra avant
bas vous surveillez qui fait que temps
vous allez lire du contenu
eh bien vous n'allez pas avoir d' écran
de veille la dernière vous avez un petit
capteur d'empreintes digitales pour
venir le déverrouiller vous appuyez paf
ça dérouille et cette année c'est plus à
cette année vous prenez votre smartphone
un peu comme ça il dit il est là et les
verrouiller vous le regardez et se
déverrouille tout de suite très
rapidement ça c'est bien alors le point
de reproche qu'on pourrait faire c'est
que même lorsque vous avez les yeux
fermés lorsque vous dormez par exemple
quelqu'un peut prendre vos smartphones
le met face à vous et ça le
déverrouiller regardez il est là bas
charles veilleux
j'appuie aidé à y envoyer cette équipe
est un petit peu embêtant imaginez vous
serez dans le train vous dormiez le
smartphone posée par tonne en face le
promu en face de vous peut déverrouiller
pareil vous dormez la nuit je sais pas
votre vos enfant qui vous voulez vient
propre marque phone le met face à votre
visage comme celles de l'infrarouge n'a
pas voulu allumer la lumière on prend
votre smartphone et on est parti et on
peut consulter votre contenu en sarre
c'est un tout qui est un petit peu
embêtant on l'a pas avec les iphone du
côté de free style vif et sa vie il faut
avoir les yeux ouverts
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait probablement potentiellement
être corrigé par google pour des
questions de sécurité
puisqu'on parle de ça je vais vous pas
d'une nouveauté que j'aime bien qui
s'appelle motion scène typiquement
lagarde et hop je prends mon smartphone
il commence on peut se débrouiller en
2010 comme de pika derrière ce qui fait
que lorsque je le prends et je le met à
la verticale comme ça il reconnaît
directement mon visage et déverrouille
ce que fait motion sense sait
reconnaître les mouvements là il
reconnaît le mouvement il reconnaît que
votre main s'approche du smartphone il
commence à réveiller pikachu ensuite je
le prends je le tourne j'ai face à moi
il est directement réveiller ça permet
d'aller beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
vite pour venir déverrouiller votre
smartphone ça c'est cool lors ya plein
d'autres choses que pouvait faire avec
motion sense puis des global c'est
qu'avec des mouvements demain vous allez
pouvoir contrôler votre smartphone alors
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas beaucoup de
mouvements encore disponibles ça
commence bien sa montre en tout cas une
ligne directrice dans laquelle semble
vouloir aller google il pourrait y en
avoir de plus en plus au fur et à mesure
du temps je vous montre ça vous allez
voir c'est assez intéressant par exemple
l'âge de mes morceaux du tout je le mets
pas trop fort pour des questions droit
d'auteur je pense que vous en douterez
en bas on voit le titre beautiful day
regardez je passe la main devant hop ça
me change s'amener sur one ici je
repasse la main devant sa demeure encore
sur un autre morceau et je remets dans
l'autre sens je repars dans le sens ça
me remet wadja pas dans notre sens ça on
et beautiful day par exemple une alarme
qui se déclenche jeu
simplement la mettre en silencieux je
passe la main devant et hop ça me répète
dans dix minutes
elle est en silencieux ces pratiques et
vous faites exactement la même chose si
quelqu'un vous appelez vous êtes dans
une réunion
le smartphone est posé sur la table il
se passionnait vous passez la main
devant terminer il est un silencieux au
moins vous êtes tranquilles car vous
n'avez pas la possibilité de venir
décrocher raccrocher tout simplement
parce que si vous faisiez le mauvais
geste vous pourriez décroché dans une
réunion où dans une situation que ce
serait compliqué
lapointe comment vous êtes tranquille
c'est déjà pratique mais l'idée de
motion scène c'est de pouvoir venir
profiter de ces caméras de les utiliser
à bon escient l'idée d'avoir des chèques
comme ça aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu
gadget tilman paraît qu'une alarme
meteren silencieux même joué que vous
mettrez dans quelques instants
mais ça pourrait avoir un sens dans les
années à venir c'est revenez en tout cas
à évoluer et à se démocratiser au pour
imager des gestes beaucoup plus fins du
capteur toujours plus précis on pourrait
imaginer des degrés de volumes ont eu
plein de choses et ça donne en tout cas
une vision du futur qui pourrait être
assez intéressante
autre point qui rigolo mais qui reste de
mettre du gadget peut venir interagir
avec votre fond d'écran ici par exemple
pika salut pic a voulu fait des coq où
il vous répond que c'est plutôt sympa
alors vous avez plein de pokémon à
quelqu'un vous pouvez venir interagir il
ya différentes façons
coucou ça va vous lui faites des grands
signes ne vous reconnais vous voyez
beaucoup pour aller plus loin grâce à un
jeu pokémon white pourrait venir ouvrir
directement comme ça à vos pokémon et
ensuite parler de la même manière vous
avez des gestes qui collabore avec vos
pokémon avec pikachu et avec tous les
autres pokémon vous leur faites des
petits gestes vous leur faites des
coucous sont très contents ils vous le
rendent bien puisque dans la gestuelle
pouvait venir naviguer maintenant
directement comme ça hop retour avant
hop on repart de l'autre côté vous avez
pas mal de possibilités
ça vient d'android disent maintenant
d'un point de vue purement expérientiel
vous avez deux haut parleurs fnac ce
vraiment bien premier haut parleurs son
côté ici là sur la façade avant deuxième
haut parleur que tu sens côté vous avez
du sang a eu très très très gros font la
qualité est là le spectre et bien il
faut que pauvreté multimédia ça marche
parfaitement dire pareil pour la partie
génie c'est vraiment cool ça marche
ayo jouant bien au delà on évite de
péter la bagnole l'audio est vraiment
aussi agréable de ce point de vue la
presse que j'ai arrêté c'est que vous
n'avez pas de freejack dessus vous avez
uniquement et c'est déjà bien du
bluetooth 5.0 nous permettra de venir à
appareiller un casque bleus poussent à
savoir derrière vous avez un sens dragon
855 6 gigaoctets de ram et 64 giga de
stockage pour la france non extensible
ça s'est un peu les points de base de
nouveaux cas est ce un peu les grosses
nouveautés on va parler de la partie
photo dans quelques instants qui est
pour moi le point phare de ce smartphone
mais on a un problème d'autonomie
c'était déjà ce que je regrettais
l'année dernière avec le pixel trois
jours mais que l'autonomie ce n'est pas
terrible ce n'est pas une journée
c'est sensiblement la même chose là
dessus je vous montre on va directement
aller dans les réglages on va aller dans
batterie voyez là il reste 7 % de
batterie ils devraient durer jusqu'à
17h30
et si vous regardez bien ce qu'il me dit
la charge complète dure 11h30
l'utilisation de l'écran depuis la
dernière charge complète 2h21 là il est
16h 50 j'ai retiré de son chargeur ce
matin à 7h25 pour être très précis dont
il ya plein de choses qui sont mises en
place pour effectivement économiser
votre batterie vous avez la batterie
intelligente qui va venir vous permettre
de gagner en autonomie
l'économiseur de batik active à partir
de 20 % au niveau de l'affichage fluide
pour vous permettre de passer bon 60
hertz lorsque vous n'avez pas besoin
d'être une 90 hertz mais dans l'état
google a pas réussi à corriger ce qui
était en tout cas pour moi le point noir
les dernières du goût de pixels 3
c'est-à-dire son autonomie on a une
batterie de 2800 millions père heures on
pourrait s'attendre à voir une grosse
batterie pour gain d'autonomie peut-être
que 3000 de a minima sorédiens 3000 5%
entre pixels 4 xl vous avez une batterie
de 3700 millan pereira là aussi un plus
grand écran qui va être un peu plus
énergivores mais sinon c'est exactement
la même chose à l'intérieur j'ai fait le
choix de passer mon smartphone en date
mode pour économiser au niveau de la
batterie parce que comme on est sur un
écran oled un pixel l'eau trafic salle
est un donc ici la consommer moins de
batterie tous âges ton c'est un petit
peu dommage alors il faut savoir par
contre que vous avez un chargeur de 18
watts qui inclut qui est plutôt bien qui
permettra de recharger assez rapidement
alors moi aussi j'ai un chargeur us
parce que je les récupère et aux états
unis lors de la présentation mais ça
c'est le truc qui en tout cas est moins
embêtant parce que ça permet de
recharger plus rapidement et ça croyez
moi ça m'embête réellement parce que
j'aime beaucoup ce smartphone la partie
photo elle est complètement nike qui
vous le montrer juste après donc bon par
contre point positif jalu recharge et 20
minutes
ça parce que forcément vu que c'est de
lui est une fois les adaptateurs
je vais leur charge et à peine 20
minutes et on est déjà à 54% de
batteries pas si voyez bien donc cette
recherche très rapidement ces pratiques
donc effectivement ça c'est un point
positif bien que tony soit pas terrible
c'est que la recharge rapide et là il
présente donc ce qui fait qu'au mieux de
votre journée ou en fin de journée si
vous avez un problème claque vous
branchez 20 minutes d'être parti jusqu'à
la fin de la journée au mans vous êtes
tranquille il tourne sur android d'ici
vendredi si un gros focus qui a été fait
au niveau de la sécu rité notamment au
niveau de la localisation sa ceinture
dont je me rendais pas forcément compte
la voyez sont toutes les applications
qui sont toujours autorisés à être
connectée à ma localisation que ça va en
permanence où je suis et ça on s'en rend
pas forcément compte et c'est quand même
relativement problématique pour celle là
les autorisations sont données
uniquement lorsque tu utilises hélas
toutes celles où ne sont pas donnés on a
quand même quelques unes on a aussi un
focus qui fait directement sur la
sécurité on à l'état de la sécurité avec
google play protect localiser mon
appareil mise à jour de sécurité mise à
jour du système googleplex tout ça c'est
quand même assez rassurant il ya une
autre nouveauté qui est vraiment sympa
c'est que votre smartphone est capable
de reconnaître les morceaux qui sont
diffusés autour de vous si vous
l'autorisez bien évidemment et auquel
cas il va venir que vous affichez le
morceau je mets un petit morceau
directement un peu loin de moi pour
qu'on n'ait pas les problèmes de droits
d'auteurs
là j'ai un morceau qui est jouée en
tâche de fond et là ils viennent de le
reconnaître directement one you tube
alors ça c'est des nouveautés qu'on peut
retrouver dans odroid 10 mais il ya un
truc qui est assez intéressant qui pokou
est vraiment réservé respecte 7,4 c'est
la dictée vocale heures dictée vocale
on pourrait se dire ok c'est des choses
qui existent mais là c'est vraiment
intéressant c'est très bleus font ça
marche bien c'est malheureusement
aujourd'hui disponible uniquement en
langue anglaise ça arrivera
prochainement en france est en tout cas
j'ai plutôt hâte que ça pourra vraiment
servir à pas mal de personnes dont
beaucoup d usage l'application s'appelle
dictaphone vous cliquez ici et vous
parler uniquement en anglais et par ayew
very happy to be with you today with my
very bad ex ante up you have the
wonderful des kiss you see you later
vous pouvez donc faire le choix de
reprendre de supprimer de terminer de
notre cas on va terminer donc on peut
bien évidemment seul réécouter comme ça
avec mon ex ans oui magnifique ça marche
bien vous avez donc toute la partie 2
vous avez la transcription la voyez ça
vole reconnaît
to be a god of war des trucs là est
vraiment hyper impressionnant pour
l'instant je dis une fois puissants
lacomblez c'est un peu frustrant mais
google nous a promis qu'on aurait très
bientôt en français ça croyez moi ça va
soulager pas mal de personnes notamment
au niveau du secrétariat
c'est juste topissime maintenant gros
focus se fait au niveau de la partie
photo parce que c'était déjà le très
gros point fort de pixels 3 l'année
dernière qu'il a mis une petite claque à
tout le monde
on a vu arriver un smartphone avec un
seul capteur qui faisait mieux que
beaucoup beaucoup de smartphones avec
plusieurs capteurs comme quoi des fois
c'est pas nous qui compte et cette année
google a voulu réitérer l'expérience
cette fois ci en mettant deux capteurs
en arrière un capteur principal de 12,2
millions pixels avec une ouverture de f
1.7 et un champ de vision de 77 degrés
bien évidemment notabilisation optique
et numérique
mais cette fois si l'on rajouté un zoom
optique 16 mégapixels ouverture de f 2.4
avec un angle de vision de 50°
stabilisation également optique
électronique
ça c'est pour l'arrière à l'avant on se
retrouve pas avec deux caméras comme
l'année dernière année on avait deux
caméras peut s'étonner on a vu une
caméra normale et une caméra nous avait
vanté le fait d'avoir des photos groupe
vous pouvez venir
élargie elle est fervente et plus de
monde là dedans là dessus on fait
machine arrière regarder une seule
caméra à l'avant pour assez facile
caméra de 8 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.0
il y avait qu un champ de vision de 90
degrés et bien évidemment vous avez deux
caméras infrarouges pour pouvoir venir
déverrouiller de façon complètement
sécurisé et c'est d'ailleurs la raison
pour laquelle on le supprime et sept
autres caméras à l'avant vous pouvez
filmer à l'arrière jusqu'à 1 4 k 1 30
images par seconde et à l'avant en 1080p
à 30 images par seconde également qu'est
ce que ça nous donne tout ça est bien se
donne un résultat qui reste dans la
lignée de ce que c'est par google c'est
à dire un truc vraiment hyper clean
hyper classe avec du matériel qui
fonctionne bien mais surtout une force
de frappe qui est incroyable derrière
d'un point de vue logiciel parce que
c'est vraiment tout l'intérêt de ce
smartphone c'est à dire que vous allez
faire les photos vous allez venir chuter
vous prenez pas la tête c'est un pote
eish août
là vous prenez votre maroc vous visez
vous appuyez et ça vous sortir une photo
qui est maximisée qui est vraiment très
très belle qu'il faut le dire
google a mis une claque à tout le monde
et continue de le faire ce qu'il faut si
avec le pixel 4 qui est un excellent
photophone enfin google a voulu garder
la même recette que les dernières et a
juste voulu améliorer ses photos avec
son zoom ce que je dois à regretter
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas voulu mettre
d'objectifs grand-angle alors que
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
constructeurs misent aujourd'hui sur les
faits et grand angle avec ses trois
optiques
c'est peut être dommage que google n'ait
pas fait le pari de miser sur l'ultra
grand pompe sur le fait d'avoir une
chose qu'il ouvrait énormément vous
savez lorsque vous êtes devant un
monument peut pas forcément
photographier lorsque votre smartphone
est équipé d'un ultra grand-angle vous
appuyez et l'avocat pts et ou alors la
qualité et pas toujours complètement
dingue il faut beaucoup lumière la
colorimétrie est souvent assez
différente de ce qu'on peut retrouver
sur le capteur principal
bon c'est un choix de la part de google
je pense que google s'est dit on garde
la même ligne on fait la même chose on
va juste optimiser le zoom les photos
sont toujours meilleurs et pour être
très clair avec vous ça marche c'est
juste assez incroyable d'ailleurs gens
se faisaient jusqu'à présent que je
prenais nos smartphones par google je
prenais un smartphone quelconque je
shootais ensuite j'aille dans google
photo jallet modifier les paramètres et
je m'étonne automatique parce que vaille
à l'algorithme de google qui est
vraiment vous améliorez votre photo et
vous apporter ce qui pouvait être de
mieux ça marchait dans ringer durée 99%
des cas c'était ce qui marchait le mieux
ce qui était vraiment bien là l'idée
avec son fils et quatre c'est que vous
n'avez plus besoin de vous endetter vous
arrivez vous visez est ce que vous voyez
à l'image ce que vous allez voir c'est à
dire un rendu qui est déjà optimisé qui
est ce qui est mieux je puis vous
assurer que entre ce que j'ai pris à new
york ce que j'ai pris à lisbonne
le rendu est là le rendu est hyper
qualitatif on se retrouve avec un point
qui était déjà très très bon et dernière
c'est à dire que vous venez là sur votre
personnage vous cliquez là où il ya la
tête
vous pouvez bouger le smartphone le
point se fera toujours au même endroit
ça c'est vachement bien
un autre paquet et rajouter c'est la
double exposition pour venir exposer
différemment en avant du sujet de
l'arrière jeu cliquez ici voyez j'ai
deux niveaux d'exposition la partie du
haut et bien se tenir et claire et
massène en règle générale et avec celle
du bas eh bien voyez je peux venir
modifier mon arrière plan là il un peu
plus foncé j'ai besoin elle éclaire un
peu plus je peux venir monter voyez ça
corrige alors ça dépend bien évidemment
de votre scène
ici on est dans une pièce qui est très
éclairé donc c'est tout un petit peu
plus compliqué mais je n'ai pas vu que
vous avez photographié des personnes qui
sont à contre jour vous avez beaucoup
l'humain derrière pas vous pouvez venir
le corriger complètement là ce qui fait
que vous allez pouvoir revenir
complètement corrigé votre phénomène de
contre jour
autre point qui est intéressant
le mode portrait que je peux dire faire
avec des objets mais aussi avec des
humains up la mode portrait claque un
petit travail qui se fait en
arrière-plan regardez ça c'est
parfaitement bien effectuer le flou est
quand même très très juste pour
marchionne sur un objet qu'on est sur
une poupée pas sur un bonhomme ça marche
plutôt bien
un autre point qui est intéressant cette
fois ci ça va le zoom tiens par exemple
regarder salle le polaroïd on zoom x 8 à
l'image il ya un peu de bruit plus
facile vous en rendez compte des jeunes
m l'a vraiment devant temps déjà c'est
très stabilisé il ya un peu de droit à
l'image
j'appuie je vais sur ma photo ce calcul
est là ça ne saurait image qui est quand
même vachement vachement clean un autre
point qui est intéressant c'est quand
vous êtes dans votre application photo
pour venir partager directement sur les
réseaux sociaux
instagram facebook et tout ce que vous
voulez il y aussi l'optimisation
logicielle clavier reconnaître les
visages que vous prenez en photo
fréquemment qui va enregistrer dans une
base de données dauvin smartphone pas en
ligne dans votre smartphone tout restons
locales pour des questions de sécurité
et qui va donc reconnaître les visages
que vous photographier le plus souvent
on veut dire optimiser les photos dès
lors que ces personnes apparaitront tu
préfères choix de l'activé s'est activée
par défaut
une fois vous l'activez si vous voulez
prévenir le désactiver et ça supprimera
toutes les données que vous avez
enregistré
mais là où ce smartphone est vraiment
cool c'est la faute aux nues il ya un
gros travail qui a été fait de la part
de google sur cet appareil pour la photo
nue ils le savent google avec le pixel 3
ils ont giflé tout le monde il des
smartphones qui sont au niveau notamment
le paie 30 pro de huawei qui marche bien
retenu il est beaucoup trop fun qui
cherchent à se hisser mais qui ont du
mal à arriver au niveau auquel google
est présent avec le pixel 3 et avec le
pixel 4 ils vont encore plus loin c'est
à dire c'est aussi vous permettre même
de faire de l'astrophotographie c'est à
dire de venir photographier les accords
malheureusement je n'ai pas pu tester le
ciel en ce moment et pas très clément
nous montrer en images je veux bien les
croire sur parole néanmoins gens
allaient pouvoir le tester
je testerai plus tard dès que le ciel me
le permettra mais quand je testerai je
publierai les images directement sur
instagram
ou alors sur mon compte twitter nous
invite à me suivre monsieur gros sur
twitter monsieur underscore greu sur
instagram protestants une petite bague
peu était à new york le jour on était
visité la station d'épuration de new
york se situe à brooklyn où il était
bien évidemment la nuit' seul endroit
qui très sombre il ya plein de vieilles
pièces qui ne servent plus à rien n'a pu
aller se balader faire des photos qui
sont intéressantes et la façon dans
lequel le pixel 4 vous
ce rendu est assez hallucinant je vous
montre ça vous intéresse vous en pensez
mais grippe en suisse quand on discute
[Musique]
ce soir il est tel résultat on a un gros
travail qui fait aussi à l'arrière d'un
point de vue logiciel pour d'autres une
fois de plus on dit chez google
bien évidemment et il travaille sur le
temps d'exposition à lorient tout cas ce
intéressant c'est à dire que vos
smartphones et de gaver de capteurs vous
avez un accéléromètre un gyroscope et
beaucoup de capteurs à l'intérieur et
donc le logiciel va être capable de
savoir si vous photographiez smartphone
à la main ou alors s'il est posé sur un
trépied en fonction de ça il va adapter
le temps d'ouverture lorsque votre
smartphone est posé sur un trépied et
que les collisions sont très très noir
donc il va venir mesurer que le
smartphone est calé va mesurer la
lumière ambiante et bien là il va ouvrir
pendant très longtemps pour capter le
maximum de luminosité et c'est là dessus
qu'ils travaillent au niveau de
l'astrophotographie il vous prend ces
images de 15 secondes on arrive à un
maximum de quatre minutes de temps
d'ouverture hélas avocate un truc qui
absolument incroyable
lorsque vous le tenez à la main lui
faire une photo ça ne durait trois
secondes maximum
vous le voyez vous avez un petit
compteur il lorsque c'est fini la photo
est en traitement et ça nous donne le
rendu qui est maximale pourrait donc sur
un smartphone clip complètement optimisé
d'un point de vue matériel logiciel pour
donner le meilleur rendu la meilleure
expérience possible aux niveaux
d'android au niveau de la photo avant le
meilleur rendu il a des défauts un
défaut majeur c'est cette batterie que
je trouve pas terrible autonomie est pas
génial j'avais espéré que ce soit
améliorée par rapport aux tics ses trois
salles l'a pas été mars c'est un peu le
point de regret à côté de ça il est
certifié et résistant à l'eau et à la
poussière ip 68 résistants avec un
corning gorilla glass 5 à l'arrière
celle à l'arrière vous mais également à
l'avant deux côtés d'ailleurs je vous
conseille vraiment de bien protéger de
ce smartphone parce que c'est toujours
important je vous le répète je vous le
répète nous martèle je sais protéger vos
smartphones il existe différents types
de protection vous avez soit les petits
pixels qu'est ce que vous propose de
google qui sont assez sympa plutôt joli
avec un toucher un peu un peu matière
vous avez les protections de mon
partenaire arino sheed solide suite vous
êtes déjà présenté sa dans la vidéo de
présentation les deux solides suite
effet carbone et fait un petit peu plus
un peu plus neutre
d'ailleurs ça vous intéresse avec 10% de
remise avec l'école monsieur bronches de
tumi en bas d'un description c'est très
important de nous protéger
même si on est encore nine gorilla glass
5 par défaut on dit que ces résistants
mais vous savez par expérience qu'à moi
je peux vous le dire je pense que
beaucoup d'entre vous le savent s'ils
tombent
un moment ou un autre c'est pas trop ça
je vous recommande donc devenir le
protéger mais en tout cas je trouve
assez intéressant c'est à dire que
j'aime la promesse qui est faite par
google c'est à dire la promesse de se
dire on a un beau photophone ont fait de
très belles photos ce smartphone là il
faut poster des photos très clairement
c'est un smartphone si vous voulez
acheter si vous voulez ce pixel 4c pour
la photographie si vous voulez acheter
depuis que cette carte pour profiter du
côté multimédia on pouvait être un petit
peu déçu parce que l'écran est pas très
grand si vous voulez côté du multimédia
à être plus sur le pixel 4xl vous aurez
la même qualité audio à l'expérience
audio est vraiment bien le pixel 4 avril
faisait signer quelqu'un qui veut un
smartphone un peu plus compact qui veut
pas un grand modèle qui veut un petit
modèle qui passent facilement dans la
poche qui est excellentissime en termes
de photos et quand je dis ça je pèse mes
mots qui est vraiment très très très bon
personnellement j'adore qui s'adresse
aussi aux personnes qui veulent
l'écosystème google qui aiment
l'écosystème google qui est quelque
chose qui complètement optimisé pour
google avec votre assistant qui était
encore amélioré pouvoir tout piloter si
vous utilisez tous les services google
ça s'est vraiment bien alors le tarif ce
que je les connais pas par coeur et
taille vous en outre et c'est là où je
ressens d'info i do not d'ailleurs ce
coup ci j'ai pas pris une feuille de
notes mais deux feuilles de notes des
baux coûteuse à vous dire
ce smartphone qui est dispo dès le 24
octobre 2019 au talent et de 769 euros
pour un modèle normal s'ils voulaient
modèle xl il goûtera 899 euros avec sa
batterie les 3700 milliards erreur et ça
il se peut vraiment que ça fasse la
différence et dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire comment
vous trouvez ce pixel 4 est ce que vous
trouvez bien plutôt réussie de la part
de google pas réussi parce que vous êtes
des filles comment ils trouvé ce petit
module photo ojlt y en a plein qui me
diront way sa copine impôts l'iphone je
pense pas on retrouve pas parce que
effectivement on a un quart et dunkerque
et cannes relativement différent le
parti pris n'est pas du tout le même au
niveau de l'intégration par google que
l'a fait en tout cas apple sait pas ce
que vous en pensez en bas et on se
retrouve dès demain pour parler de tout
autre chose
tout aussi intéressant sur ce je vous
embrasse à demain et puis des gros
bisous tout